hello everybody hope that you are good I
know that today it's Saturday and I
usually don't update you on Saturdays
but come on there is a lot of price
volatility a lot of price movement
especially because yesterday we had the
worst day in the stock market since the
co crash in 2020 and that was because we
had a very weak labor market data when
employment rate going to
43% uh triggering the the Sam rule um
recession indicator and there is now a
lot of fear for a recession coming in
come on the volatility index yesterday
did 45% in just one day so there is a
lot to talk about here and in this video
I'm going to talk about many different
things I'm going to talk first about
Bitcoin in lower time frame just a
little bit because tomorrow I'm posting
the usual Bitcoin soon the update on X
also I'm going to be talking about
something a bit more interesting perhaps
and is Bitcoin in higher time frame um
because I do think that we are in a
moment that both bulls and bears might
be correct perhaps not as they think but
and usually both are wrong bears and
bulls and bears and different things
happening but I do believe that we might
see a bit of volatility in the next
months um especially before the
elections then we'll see what happens
after the elections but this time
between August and November I do believe
it's going to be very volatile for
Bitcoin and also of course I have to
talk about the CME gap on bitcoin that
we are approaching and of course the
Bitcoin dominance and also some altcoins
well ethereum I'm going to talk about
ethereum and some Al coins such as chain
link also fet avac Solana and I do want
to talk about a scenario a high time
frame scenario that I keep in my in my
mind for Bitcoin that I think that it's
good to share it with you in case it
does happen you can be prepared for it
again it's just a scenario that I have
my head it might happen it might not
play out but uh and it's up to you what
to do with this video but um if he
actually end up happening then if you've
watched this video and it helps you and
and it help you to be prepared for it
maybe there is a good opportunity there
for you so uh I'm going to tell you how
I'm going to play it the first thing is
Bitcoin in lower time frame so we've
been talking these days that Bitcoin
needed to hold above 64,000 which is the
daily 50 m same as it happened here here
we got a retest here we got another
retest here and we're waiting a retest
on Thursday and on Thursday I mentioned
that because it's Thursday and will only
had Thursday and Friday and then the
weekend is very ER what it was meant to
be quite flat price action I was I was
mentioning that I need to see a few
candles closing above the daily 50ma to
give me con conviction wow look at that
Loop that to give me conviction that
we're going to come again to this highs
okay otherwise we have the risk of
dropping back to the range lows at
60,800 where in the 4 hours time frame
we can see a liquidity pull that my
indicator was marking here okay that
liquidity pool that you can see that
that low there is
6,800 where I put some bits last night
and this morning where hit again bits in
a spot not in leverage
because careful with the volatility and
I usually don't trade over the weekend
but uh I do believe that this weekend is
going to be quite volatile and the first
option that I see is that if we go into
the one or time frame I do believe that
it's possible that over the weekend we
see some upside to the 1 hour 50 May to
63,000 okay that's between today and
tomorrow so that's the thing that I'm
paying attention to then the thing that
worries me the most is that if I apply
the we F St into the
indicator then we're want to notice guys
how we have a long week at the lows and
long weeks tend to get filled look at
these line you see all these lines here
at the left those are previous weeks and
they fade because they've been filled we
have a chance of around 95% to get
filled so it's really a matter of time
in principle that this week gets filled
careful with Bitcoin at the moment
because it's showing signs of high
volatility and it's difficult to predict
how it's going to react but I do think
that this week is going to get failed
now if we in the case that we start to
go up and leave this week behind then
that will also be a cause of concern
because again weeks T to get fill
superhubs which is something like this
and that is when we come to the
conclusion of the weekly 50ma cuz if you
notice guys the weekly 50ma hasn't been
retested for quite a long time I mean
look at this he played here a support
again here then here as resistance here
as support and since then since October
last year we
haven't really touched it and if you
check what happens in previous bull
market we see something quite similar we
can see that price is usually hovering
around the the the weekly 50 minut and
then when we see a um a price an
aggressive and impulsive price move such
as this one here then it tends to go and
test it as support for another move why
not why is that not happening right now
guys it's for you to D but look at this
impulsive move come and tested
consolidate another leg up okay that's
what I mean that both bears and Bulls
might be correct and right now the
weekly 50ma is a 53,000 for that you
would also be
feeling
this Gap here that we got a 58,000 that
we haven't really entered yet thinking
that we're want to fill we're want to
retrace the C Gap uh soon which also
would align with the idea of Bitcoin
going to the weekly 50 ma where I do
believe that there is a high chance of
holding a support and then from there we
can see that next leg up and make new
highs as the buol say so that's what I'm
telling you guys perhaps this time both
bulls and bears are correct that's
perhaps knowing the way they mean it
and this being said then if that
actually plays out over the next few
months and we come and test the weekly
50 me at 53,000 right now although it
continues going up of course which is a
dynamic Target so perhaps next week is a
54,2 who knows so pay attention to that
level there all right now if that
happens
then where do you want to be positioned
into well the first thing is pay
attention to the Bitcoin dominance
because the Bitcoin dominance keeps
going up super bullish still um you can
see here that we were in a range for 2
years then we broke above the range then
we have this pump here and then the
retrace or the support retest that I
also mention in this Channel and it
happened and at this level to be honest
I was quite confused because I didn't
know what to expect from the Bitcoin
dominance because it's true that we were
testing it as resistance for quite some
time and I didn't know if this was at
the end here this part here if this
Wasing into a deviation
or into a resistance support flip and
there is actually a retest of support of
that resistance which seems that that's
the case and is still looking qu bullish
like come on it can still go to 60% why
not and if that is the case and it
happens then alins are going to take um
another hit more than Bitcoin cuz when
Bitcoin drops yesterday for example
Bitcoin dropped I don't know how much
let me check very quickly Bitcoin
dropped go to the Daily time frame so
it's this candle here yesterday's Daily
candle is 5.9% so that Bitcoin yesterday
dropped
5.9% and I know that alins dropped more
like a 8% for example check Solana check
avax check um I don't know chain link
they they they took a bigger hit and I
do believe this is something that is
going to continue happening as long as
the Bitcoin dominance go goes up
strongly as it is now okay and now
everything is bad because again if you
are prepared for this and Bitcoin
actually drops ends up dropping to the
weekly 50ma that right now is
53,486 is a 133% drop or 12% drop Al
might going down maybe 20% from what
where they are right now okay and again
that could give us good opportunities
that's what I'm putting my attention
right now we're going to go to now to
ethereum and ethereum chart is very
clean and ethereum trades very nicely
and you can see here that at the bottom
of the bare Market we did some kind of
consolidation we did this range here
okay these are the range lows range
highs little deviation there range highs
then a drop to the range meid and you
have there the impulsive move up which
usually happens after going a r to the
range mid something that I've noticed
that happens qual of of times inside
ranges and now we're forming a new range
in the weekly time frame what you can
see here the range size then also you
can see here a little deviation with
that week there okay again range highs
and all of this is range lows very
clearly so now the two levels that I'm
keeping an eyeon for ethereum the first
thing that I imagine is that if Bitcoin
goes and drop to the weekly 50 ma
ethereum of course going to do the it's
going to the same which is very close
it's even closer than to bitcoin and for
that I would imagine that we might see
some kind of deviation below this range
uh to 2,700 is and if that is the the
case then I would probably in the case
of ethereum wait to recover the range to
be more clear about the structure and
that's when you can open spot buys okay
cuz you're going to have the certainty
that the next move is going to be to the
range Highs at least and possibly a
breakout now in the other case that an
actual recession comes in the next 3
months or so um the stock market just
start dropping very fast because usually
when we see a recession the stock market
tends to drop at least 30% uh only in
1990 that was a very small recession
that lasted 8 months the S&P dropped uh
18% I think it was so EI either way if
you get recession this year later this
year the stock market is going to drop
Bitcoin is going to drop and obviously
ethereum is not going to do this
deviation but it could continue dropping
lower back to the range highs of this
previous accommodation range that's a
2,000
all right so that would be in my opinion
the worst case scenario um I don't
imagine falling back into this range and
going into the range lows I don't really
see that happening at Le for now but I'm
looking for this scenario of a deviation
to
2,700 then see what happens and the next
Target in case of recession literally
that's the only thing I can imagine that
would push us lower it would be to 2,000
to this Range High we would find
support and then if we go into other Al
coins then we can go for example into
chain link chain link is perhaps not the
best Alco but it's an Alco that is used
by a lot of projects that it has a a
real use and it has um a lot of yeah a
lot of projects back back in Europe
and a lot of investors because I still I
noticed that people still believe in
chaining um to be honest it hasn't it
hasn't performed bad at all we at here
range over a year and a half if we go
from the range lows it did time three
so overall not about not about
performance to be honest Al of course
Bitcoin has done better and anyway what
I want to mention here is that if
Bitcoin actually goes to the weekly 50
ma then is going to drop again to
the top another loop this happen this
keeps happening to me taing is going to
drop to this Range High here okay of
this previous accomodation range of over
a year and a half which I would
naturally expect it to test it and to
act as support okay so yes
9.60 that's the level for Ching in my
opinion and this drop if you notice guys
it's a 20% drop what we said if Bitcoin
drops 12% Alin can be dropping around
20% so that would be my target for chain
link now if we move into different Alin
you have for example f
which is H the strongest artificial
intelligence Al right now in the market
although I think it's merging into ASI I
think it's still happening if I'm not
mistaken although I'm not I haven't been
following it for a while but if you
notice here with Fi we have a very clear
pattern that it's going up aggressively
and going down aggressively now if
there's a few things that I've noticed
about fi the first thing is that these
drops tend to be look at this one 80%
that the next
one
80% the next
73% and this one so far that we are
experiencing right now that one so far
is 70% right now but why not can I not
continue going lower especially if
Bitcoin those of course yes and I'm
going to show you the Target that I keep
in mind but also another thing that I
want you to notice is that how fi tends
to always go back to the previous uh
let's say resistance okay as you can see
that going back to the same area if you
notice here you got a weak here you mark
it and boom in the next retrace it goes
there right hang on I messed it up there
so something that we could be seeing is
essentially FCI going back for example
to this area here all right and that is
basically 0 to 80 that's what I'm
keeping an eye on for for h f now if you
go into the daily time frame you can
find perhaps some more
justification
with this liquidity pool right here okay
you can see more clearly here that how
this could act as support okay now
technical analysis might be discussing
that this is a a Bish pennant I don't
even know how to draw this there okay
and it breaks to the downside so in my
opinion 8 is an area that I wouldn't
mind to buy some fetch now next Al coin
this is aex aex is a coin that I really
like and that I want to have in my
portfolio in this cycle um for a few
reasons the first reason is that is that
it's a coin that trades very nicely and
you can see here how we were drawing
this potential deviation we got it and
then the pump that it was at time six
600% up uh similar to what Bitcoin did
in terms of performance so respect to be
honest because no not many altcoins
perform the same performed in the same
way as Bitcoin most of them
underperformed Bitcoin so far in this
cycle and I have respect for that also
the next thing is that there is a lot of
projects using this blockchain which of
course that's great because it generates
revenue for the project which can help
them to continue improving increasing
the size of their team their marketing
the different different new projects
that they might want to do or
improvements so yeah that's a good thing
and so far if you notice aax is been
dropping a lot and it's tooking a big
hit to be honest and it's already here
in this range highs that we had you can
see how we tested it here support and it
seems that we are going to do that again
now if we are looking for a drop of
20% Then avax which go would go to
around $119
$20 now my only hope here is that that
would turn out to be a
deviation before more upside because you
going do deviations back inside the
range so that's my hope that if that
happens and it continues dropping it
form a deviation so I don't have a very
clear Target for aax in terms of a level
but the idea is there that if it drops
you want to see the deviation so perhaps
you can even wait until this moment here
to buy okay just to be safe and of
course in terms of there is a refes and
stuff of course you're want to go back
to this lows here to it's not something
that I'm expecting okay I I do think
that we might see something like this so
with this video don't get scared guys
just understand the the scenario that
I'm talking about and understand that
it's something that could possibly
happen and it's not that crazy that
Bitcoin goes and test the weekly 50 May
and if you are ready and prepared for
that you might catch a good opportunity
there also Solana in my opinion Solana
it's uh well it's my favorite arcoin and
it's insane how how this coin
outperform the entire Market it's insane
I think they just beat BNB also in
market capitalization so uh it's insane
what they are doing and and again it's a
project that is been used well it's a
blockchain that is been used by projects
which makes them make money and by
making money they can do a lot of good
things for the project so um that's
something that I also pay attention a
lot and is that if there Alin is
actually making money because I don't
want to invest into a project into a
team that is not been able to make money
so Sola is one of those ones that
actually make a lot of money and but all
of you know about that and I don't see
much of a drop here because I don't
think that if you notice any deep that
we've seen it gets heavily bought
instantly so yes perhaps the same as
Bitcoin guys a
retest of this weekly 50ma which is a
20% drop and that sit right now at 119
that is or 118 yeah that's my buying
price if it goes there I buy because I
don't think that it's going to get
heavily bought and I can continue going
up and how much can go
guys it wouldn't surpr surpris me to be
honest seeing it going to this area here
between 800 and and 600 it wouldn't
surprise me at all okay and for that you
have more than a Time six time seven so
that's something that I'm um paying
attention to in general uh I think the
ALCO that I've talked about uh they are
good projects um so ABB because um
they're very solid projects and they
make a lot of money traing people are
still use chain well projects still use
chain link and people still buy chain
link so so perhaps he doesn't do our
time six or time seven like Solana but
maybe do at time three and it's
safe and then fi I want to keep an eye
on what what is happening with that
mergin because I thought they already
did it and I don't see that happening
yet I don't think they've done it yet so
that's something that I want to keep an
eye on to be able to TR the project and
invest in it and then of course you have
um ethereum what can I tell you about
ethereum ethereum it's it's it's going
to do I think a massive rally I do think
that ethereum has a lot of room to go um
very high and I'm talking about $7,000
$88,000 uh easily okay in the case that
we actually get that bull run that we're
expecting that so far we've had some but
come on we want a bit more of of
continuation ethereum hasn't broke the
highs yet and that's at $5,000 we've
only gone to $4,000 so there is still a
lot of room there for ethereum to go and
that's pretty much everything guys so I
hope that this video comes helpful time
will tell if it actually happens of that
retest of the weekly 50 may eventually
and we see those targets that I
mentioned for this Alin getting hit and
if that is the case then I don't know
maybe this video helps you to be
prepared for it but again it's not
Financial advice just my analysis so
thank you so much for watching guys and
I'll see you soon